- Hm … Nachtisch.
- Hm … Sieht toll aus!
- Vielen Dank!
- Bitte!
Ich möchte nicht,
dass du hungrig nach Hause gehst.
Du musst probieren!
- Sind in Syrien alle
Menschen so gastfreundlich?
- Ja.
Aber in Deutschland auch.
Ich hab' den Eindruck, dass viele
Verhaltensregeln sehr ähnlich sind.
- Da musst du Nico fragen,
er ist der Experte.
- Hm?
- Ich verstehe.
Darum die Frage nach der Familie.
- Ich habe gelesen, dass es höflich ist,
zu fragen, wie es der Familie geht.
- Wenn man die Familie kennt, ja.
Aber es ist toll,
dass du dich informiert hast.
- Auf Wiedersehen!
- Tschüss!
Und vielen Dank für das tolle Essen.
- Bis bald!
- Danke.
- Selma und du …
Das ist ja wohl glasklar.
- Leider nicht.
Es ist sogar ziemlich kompliziert …